[Music]
Tom Hanks is coming to his wife Rita
Wilson's defense she puts up with a lot
anyway so what good what can I do after
every night they're followed by a swarm
of people as they head toward their SUV
but at one point Rita trips after
somebody bumps into her from behind
[Music]
but Tom's stepping in to protect his
wife should come as no surprise because
their 34-year marriage is Rock Solid
she's a big influence on my ability to
do what I do so and everybody should be
so lucky with their lover E.T spoken
with the couple many times over the
years and it's pretty obvious they're
madly in love this is one of the most
classically beautiful women who's ever
walked to planet Earth I can't believe
she's married to me uh she could have
done better but I'm a lucky man he
absolutely makes me laugh and that's I
mean he's when we met years and years
and years ago we're getting ready to
celebrate our 29th wedding anniversary
he made me laugh back then and he still
makes me laugh now clearly nothing can
knock this power Duo down instead the
two are enjoying their time in the Big
Apple while Tom promotes his latest
flick Elvis
I wish to promote you Mr Presley
tomorrow all America will be talking
about
in the biopic
to jerk colonel Colonel Parker and when
ET spoke with Austin Butler who plays
The Rock and Roll legend he opened up
about working with an oscar-winning icon
like Tom I didn't know what it was going
to be like when I first met him because
he's been my hero for as long as I can
remember and so when I first met him as
our baza's house in Australia and I see
him from Far ways back in the in the
backyard and I come walking up and he
goes my boy and he holds out his arms
and gives me the biggest bear hug that
was my first interaction and then baz
walked away and then and then Tom just
started sharing his feelings of fear
around portraying these two men and then
I could say you're afraid I'm terrified
and then and then we were colleagues and
then we could talk about our
vulnerabilities and that was a gift that
he gave me you know what the universe
does for you
foreign